the game awards what generally has been
referred to as the cringe awards I don't
really get why not everything is cringe
okay
as to the front of the stage rework hide
robot okay
oh this year 2017 game awards a
disappointing amount of cringe
I'm letdown what happened what went
wrong this year just felt more like the
ad Awards 2017 cuz my god there was more
ads than a pretty pipe ten minute video
that's a lot of ads boy alright the
sales going on tonight already give you
special discounts on the best games but
this year we're going next level by
partnering with eBay 50% off a HyperX
headset but now it's time for the final
offer a brand new 34 inch LG widescreen
monitor for almost half off but let's
review this year as people online I was
like well you didn't present every award
and it's like I don't think we ever
really want to present like every
individual genre war but we want to
create different kinds of awards elevate
the genre by coming up with new awards
such great new award titles as most
anticipated game presented by mecha cafe
truly an award to be proud of what did
you win most anticipated game by Mac
cafe EXO we'll be right back after this
mcDonald's congratulate all the nominees
Jesus Christ can you imagine the Oscars
having most anticipated movie award what
a great idea hey hey I'm sorry I was
just kidding
it was a joke it was a joke and this
shows that the gaming industry built so
much on just hype in my opinion how many
times have you been let down by the
release of the game come on we're on
every platform out there tonight we're
on Facebook or on YouTube and 4k
PlayStation Steam GameSpot IGN Xbox and
we're also streaming on Mountain Dew Hey
look it's another zombie game everybody
oh wow that's that's really fun original
and exciting I really enjoy myself a
good old zombie game what zombie game
are they gonna make next I always ask
myself when I wake up if the game
doesn't have zombies then why bother the
game is zombies if it's not zombies
why bother and right now it's my honor
to announce the first Award winner of
the night for trending gamer moonlight
best picture trending gamer is dr.
disrespect congratulations
oh that's awesome are you the doctor
what doing it to see you could die to
see you was he just hiding behind the
camera my god he must have a futuristic
mission through the glasses it's almost
like he knew he were just gonna win the
award
that's incredible this is your trophy so
congratulations cut me it's very heavy
[Applause]
[Music]
okay okay that game was cool I
definitely want to play it good job
wow the announcement so far has been
pretty lackluster and uninteresting I'm
actually quite disappointed oh my god
blood-borne - that's all you get a
little tease of the next project a gif
from from software thank you very much
guys for that little tease of what
they're working on next edward try back
the composer of Star Wars The Old
Republic he's put together an amazing
tribute to the music a game so you guys
ready to do this yes the music is always
the best part of get yours
always
[Music]
the streamers and the communities on
Twitch tonight are able to predict what
they think is gonna win each category so
if you're on Twitter's a twitch
extension you can predict as you're
watching this show live to see who you
thinks gonna win the best action game
category right now fans on Twitch are
predicting that Cup hat is going come on
I need some video game announcements
give me a game that I can truly play for
my channel something that I actually
care about but right now let's move on
to world premieres tonight yes here we
go an honor that some of the top game
developers in the world chose in the
game Awards the place to reveal the
first news on their next projects oh wow
that was pretty good
[Music]
and the game award goes oh man I have to
pay a micro transaction to unlock that's
so stupid that this has to hold on I got
this guy's everything that's not true
you didn't actually have to be Michael
ei sucks
and we right pound it pound pound the
screen if you hate ei sure I'm getting a
bag I'm [ __ ] this mess deliver right
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow that the graphics in this game look
amazing it stands out for anything else
we've seen it's almost like they're
showing a movie trailer at the game
Awards
I wonder if they do that at the Oscars
they show a game trailer at the Oscars
you keep coming me stop can you just
stop okay just stop I'm trying to help
you guys do you not understand how many
times do I gotta tell you
never never brofist onstage never
handshake onstage if you're live don't
do anything
no human interactions with other people
on live television okay you don't want
to end up like Adam Sandler touching
Annie goes I got nominated for a Golden
Globe too so I took my parents just do
us all a favor okay from the people that
have already suffered I don't want you
all to suffer anymore no brofist no
handshakes and no knee touching
the wait is over let's begin Wow
so caliber looks really good yep it
looks like it's gonna be a good game
definitely somewhat of a decent game
[Music]
was that a is that a baby inside Norman
Reedus 10 out of 10 best game this one
wins
honestly that trailer was really cool I
almost want Kojima just to make movies
at this point it's clear that that's
where he's passionate I'm so passionate
to be here I'm so excited to be and
meeting this industry we're here
services look the Oscars should [ __ ]
themselves up this is the [ __ ] I'm
telling you this is this is the real
[ __ ]
okay can you swear here okay [ __ ] the
Oscars you know the gaming industry it's
an interactive lot of films and now
you're in games yeah that's right you
know I've done six features about yeah
but okay we're here to talk about our
way out let's do it guys yeah let's get
into your game jet lag also known as
cocaine okay here we gonna finally
announce a game of the error game of the
years persona 51 global media outlets
and the fans and this year the game of
the war game of the year goes to
moonlight best picture